(victorious music)
- It's okay to be different.
It's okay to not look
like the normal person.
It's okay to get outside
your comfort zone
and be courageous,
even if people don't like it.
As long as it's positive,
then you should press forward with it.
(victorious music)
My name is Isaiah Griffin,
and I am a bodybuilder.
When I was 17 to 18, I developed
this condition called keloids.
Basically when your
body over heals itself.
It started as bumps every now and then
that would burst open that
looked like regular acne.
Then they started to just
connect and make the web,
basically on my chest.
In the earlier stages
of having my keloids,
honestly I didn't understand
it or how to feel about it.
I wasn't in the mirror so much.
There would be times where I
would just wash my face,
turn the lights off.
Mentally, it messed with my confidence.
I had depression from it,
but mainly, worried about, focused on,
what other people think in companionship.
But slowly but surely,
I just started wearing
tank tops in the gym to where I would feel
like I'm overcoming whatever's
battling on the outside
or inside.
It was something new,
something completely different.
I want to work towards
being a world champion.
But this journeys more
about self-improvement,
more than it is reviving
any medals or anything.
Being a champion is nice,
but I need to see the real
meaning with what I'm doing.
When I see myself in the mirror now,
I just see myself, I love myself.
I look past the scars and just see
the person who doesn't
want to accept the norm'.
There's an African proverb:
"If there's no enemy within,
the enemy outside can do us no harm."